danke nach Berlin und herzlich
willkommen zu einem kurzen ZDF Spezial
an diesem richtungsweisenden Tag
[Musik]
Kampfpanzer liefern oder nicht der
Prozess der Abwägung und Abstimmung hat
etwas gedauert und auch heute dauerte es
noch mal sieben Minuten bis
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz in seiner Rede
im Bundestag die Lieferung der
Kampfpanzer ankündigte sieben Minuten in
den er schilderte auf welchen Wegen die
Entscheidung zustande kam es ist
wirklich Krieg in Europa sagte stolz und
wollte wohl deutlich machen warum sich
die Bundesregierung so behutsam an neue
Schritte herantastet Patricia Wiedemeier
fast den Tag in Berlin zusammen
lange hat er sich Zeit gelassen lange
hat er geschwiegen selten war der
öffentliche Druck so hoch wie in den
letzten Tagen und Wochen doch Olaf
Scholz lässt sich nicht treiben weder
von der polnischen Regierung noch von
der Opposition noch von der eigenen
Koalition heute endlich erklärte er sich
im Bundestag und rechtfertigte sein
Zögern alle diese Entscheidung haben wir
im Einklang und in enger Kooperation mit
unseren Verbündeten getroffen das ist
der Grund warum sie wirksam sind und
warum wir sie auch treffen konnten das
ist das Prinzip dass diese Regierung hat
schon am Morgen im Kabinett hatte Scholz
seine Entscheidung verkündet niemals
werde er alleine Waffensysteme
bereitstellen vertrauen Sie mir
vertrauen Sie der Bundesregierung wir
werden weiter weil wir international
abgestimmt Handeln sicherstellen dass
diese Unterstützung möglich ist ohne
dass die Risiken für unser Land darüber
in eine falsche Richtung wachsen in
einem ersten Schritt sollen jetzt 14
Leopard Panzer aus Bundeswehr bestellen
zur Verfügung gestellt werden auch
weitere Länder erhalten die Genehmigung
Leos zu liefern insgesamt bis zu 90
könnten es am Ende werden weiter ging es
am Nachmittag nach dem Treffen mit der
isländischen Ministerpräsidentin äußerte
sich Scholz erneut zum Thema
panzerlieferung ja aber das sei nicht
alles neben den Panzern um dies jetzt
geht haben wir auch weiter vor das was
wir geliefert haben zu ergänzen wenn es
um Flugabwehrsysteme schwere Artillerie
mehrfach Raketenwerfer und ähnliches
gibt am Abend dann noch eine öffentliche
Erklärung in der ZDF-Sendung was nun
verteidigte Scholz erneut seine
zögerliche Haltung wer panzerlieferer
müsse starke Nerven haben
unverantwortlich wäre anders zu handeln
und deshalb habe ich mich auch niemals
von irgendwem treiben lassen und
beeindrucken lassen als all die lauten
Rufe feuchten habe ich gedacht das kann
man verantwortlich nicht machen jeden
Abend schon viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Fernsehen und hoffen dass die Regierung
und dass der Kanzler die Nerven behält
und den kann ich versichern das war so
und das wird auch so bleiben besonnen
bleiben keine Alleingänge das war die
Botschaft des Kanzlers heute von
möglichen eigenen Fehlern kein Wort
in Berlin begrüße ich den
CDU-Vorsitzenden guten Abend Herr Merz
guten Abend die Würfel sind gefallen was
den Leopard 2 betrifft was überwiegt
jetzt bei Ihnen die Zustimmung zu dieser
Entscheidung oder die Enttäuschung über
verlorene Zeit
es ist eine Kombination aus beidem die
Entscheidung ist richtig ich will aber
auch noch einmal hinzufügen davon auf es
macht sich ja keiner leicht das ist eine
schwere Entscheidung wir haben diese
Entscheidung seit einigen Wochen für
richtig gehalten wir wissen dass wir
damit in Übereinstimmung standen mit
vielen Mitgliedern der Europäischen
Union und der NATO wir haben es für
falsch gehalten dass der Bundeskanzler
so lange gezögert hat und sich
offensichtlich drängen lassen musste zu
dieser Entscheidung aber die
Entscheidung selbst ist nach Abwägung
auch auf unserer Seite richtig es ist im
Bundeskanzler aber auch gelungen die USA
zur Lieferung von Kampfpanzern zu
bewegen getreu seinem Credo niemals
allein hat Scholz also letztlich alles
richtig gemacht
niemals allein ist eine richtige
Botschaft die haben wir auch nie
bestritten die Frage ist nur mit wem und
da hätte vielleicht auch eine etwas
engere Abstimmung mit den europäischen
NATO-Staaten stattfinden sollen und der
Bundeskanzler hätte am letzten Sonntag
eine Chance gehabt mit dem französischen
Staatspräsidenten zusammen hier auch
eine gemeinsame Entscheidung wenigstens
anzukündigen und zu sagen es wird in
dieser Woche eine Entscheidung in dieser
Frage gegeben die wir beide der
französische Staatspräsident und der
deutsche Bundeskanzler abgestimmt haben
ich habe den Eindruck in den letzten
Wochen zunehmend bekommen und auch heute
Abend in der Fernsehsendung beim
Zuschauen erneut bestätigt gefühlt das
Olaf Scholz offensichtlich allein den
amerikanischen Staatspräsidenten für
denjenigen hält der auf seine Augenhöhe
spielt und der mit ihm zusammen dann
Entscheidungen trifft in Europa
hinterlässt das viel Verstimmung
die Ukraine zu stärken ohne einen Krieg
zwischen Russland und der NATO
wahrscheinlicher zu machen das ist der
Kurs der Bundesregierung deshalb gibt es
rote Linien etwa Kampfjets oder
Bodentruppen unterstützen sie das
wir sind uns völlig einig dass die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und die
Europäische Union auch die NATO hier
nicht zum Kriegs zur Kriegspartei werden
darf diese roten Linien gibt es ohne
Zweifel die haben wir auch nie in Abrede
gestellt das war immer unsere gemeinsame
Haltung zusammen mit der Bundesregierung
viele Menschen in Deutschland das wollen
wir hier nicht verhehlen machen sich
Sorgen dass wir in diesen Krieg
hineingezogen werden könnten wie real
ist diese Gefahren
wir setzen uns mit diesen sorgen sehr
ernsthaft aufeinander kommen allerdings
zu einem anderen Ergebnis und dieses
Ergebnis lautet wenn wir nicht in der
Lage sind Putin zu stoppen dann macht er
weiter und wir sagen das ja nicht nur so
sondern wir meinen es dieser Krieg
bedroht nicht nur die Ukraine er bedroht
ganz Europa er bedroht die politische
Ordnung des europäischen Kontinents und
der bedroht damit auch unsere Freiheit
und deswegen verteidigen wir mit der
Ukraine unsere Freiheit und deswegen
müssen wir der Ukraine helfen und ich
meine wir hätten es früher und
intensiver tun müssen sehen Sie Herr
März dann 1 Szenario das noch vielleicht
in diesem Jahr zu einem Waffenstillstand
oder gar einem Frieden führen könnte
ich kann es mir im Augenblick unter den
gegenwärtigen Umständen nicht vorstellen
die alle hoffen es aber wir wissen aus
der Geschichte übrigens auch aus der
deutschen Geschichte dieser Krieg hat
nicht am 24 Februar 2022 erst angefangen
er hat bereits im Frühjahr des Jahres
2014 angefangen wir hätten früher Stopp
sagen müssen und da vorne auf erlauben
Sie mir den Hinweis zu geben wir haben
im letzten Jahr mit dieser
Bundesregierung zusammen eine gemeinsame
Entscheidung getroffen über 100
Milliarden sogenannte Sondervermögen für
die Bundeswehr das alles musste unter
großen Zeitdruck entschieden werden es
sind bis zum heutigen Tag aus diesen 100
Milliarden Euro keine Aufträge erteilt
worden es ist nichts bestellt worden und
der Verteidigungshaushalt im nächsten
Jahr singt er ist gegenüber dem Vorjahr
um 300 Millionen Euro zurückgenommen
worden sie verstehen vielleicht auch
deshalb weil wir dass wir skeptisch sind
und dass wir zweifeln auch in den
Zusagen die die Bundesregierung in den
letzten Monaten gegeben hat wir ein
bisschen weiter sein können Beschaffung
bei der Bundeswehr war auch unter CDU
und CSU Verteidigungsministerin immer
schwierig würde der Kanzler an dieser
Stelle sagen jetzt haben wir aber keine
Zeit mehr das weiter zu diskutieren
einmal herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
Erleichterung in vielen westlichen
Ländern die selbst auch Leopard 2
liefern wollen und dies jetzt dürfen
Moskau reagierte dagegen wenig
überraschend erst mit Drohungen und
schließlich mit Schulterzucken die
Zusage aus Berlin nennen viele Zeitungen
heute überall auf der Welt historisch in
einer entscheidenden Phase des Krieges
unsere korrespondentinnen und
Korrespondenten fassen die Reaktionen
aus Brüssel Washington und Moskau
zusammen
bisher schwanken die Reaktionen aus
Moskau zwischen Drohungen und den
Versuchen die möglichen Auswirkungen auf
den Kriegsverlauf die die
panzerlieferung haben könnten klein zu
reden da ist zum Beispiel kremlsprecher
Peskow der meint wer jetzt glaubt dass
die Ukraine dadurch große Vorteile
erringen würde der überschätze die
Fähigkeiten der ukrainischen Armee die
Sprecherin des russischen
Außenministeriums wiederum maria
sachadow war die sagt die Aussagen
deutscher Politiker würden belegen ich
zitiere dass der Krieg gegen Russland
schon lange geplant worden sei das ist
eine steile These ohne Belege aber es
ist nichts was wir so oder so ähnlich
nicht schon früher gehört hätten eine
Verschärfung der Tonlage ist derzeit
nicht zu erkennen
nach außen lobt der US-Präsident
Deutschland aber das Verhältnis ist
angeknackst man habe Berlin eigentlich
nie gedrängt umgekehrt habe das aber
jetzt Berlin mit Washington gemacht und
damit den Eindruck erzeugt so heißt es
hinter den Kulissen als sei man bereit
zuzulassen dass Russland diesen Krieg
gewinnt
Amerika wünscht sich das Deutschland
eine Führungsverantwortung übernimmt als
schlüsselstaat für Sicherheit und
Stabilität in Europa und wenn man dafür
aber ins Panzer liefern muss dann ist
das eben so auch wenn es militärisch
eigentlich überhaupt gar keinen Sinn
macht sie sind ein Albtraum für jeden
ukrainischen Kommandeur auf dem
Schlachtfeld weil er unterschiedliche
Technologien unterschiedliche Nachschub
und Versorgungswege berücksichtigen muss
aber man hat dadurch es nun hinbekommen
dass die verbündeten sich alle darauf
verpflichten ein Strategiewechsel
vorzunehmen es geht nicht mehr nur um
Defensive sondern auch um Offensive die
Ukraine Stück für Stück zurück zu
erobern und darauf haben sich alle
verpflichtet auch Deutschland
die Entscheidung von Bundeskanzler
Scholz hat Europa mit großer
Erleichterung aufgenommen die Mitglieder
der Europäischen Union sind froh dass
sie wieder mit einer Stimme sprechen das
ist ein wichtiges Signal an Moskau denn
der Streit über die Bewaffnung der
Ukraine drohte Europa zu spalten und zu
schwächen das gilt auch für die NATO
Generalsekretär Stoltenberg lobte Scholz
Entscheidung die panzerlieferung könnte
der Ukraine helfen den Krieg zu gewinnen
allerdings hat der Streit auch eines
gezeigt wie sensibel das Thema ist viel
Europäer haben Angst dass bei der
nächsten Debatte die gerade gewonnene
Einheit wieder verloren geht
guten Abend Katrin Eigendorf sie sind
für uns in der Ukraine in hakif heute
waren sie in kremators unterwegs wie ist
die Entscheidung Deutschlands von den
Menschen dort aufgenommen worden
ja wir haben gestern den ganzen Tag und
auch die Nacht in grammatosk verbracht
und das ist ja eine Stadt die ist nur 30
Kilometer vom schwer umkämpften bachmut
entfernt das heißt die Menschen da sind
direkt bedroht und fürchten sich
wirklich davor dass möglicherweise die
Ukraine die russische Armee vordringen
könnte in ihre Stadt die Angst dort ist
einfach permanent spürbar und deswegen
ist diese Entscheidung die Deutschland
jetzt getroffen hat dort von den
Menschen mit denen wir gesprochen haben
mit großer Erleichterung und auch Freude
aufgenommen worden die Menschen haben
uns gesagt diese Panzer könnten einfach
den Unterschied in diesem Krieg machen
aus ihrer Sicht und es ist interessant
wie sich einfach Zivilisten mittlerweile
mit solchen militärischen Fragen auch
beschäftigen wie viele dort über Leopard
Panzer reden der Name ist in aller Munde
was ich aber auch gehört habe von
einigen Menschen ist Angst davor dass es
möglicherweise jetzt zu
Vergeltungsschlägen von russischer Seite
kommen könnte das ist eine Befürchtung
ja die die Menschen dort auch betreibt
was hören sie denn von offizieller Seite
reicht der ukrainischen Regierung die
Lieferung Lieferung von insgesamt etwa
90 Leopard Panzern davon 14 aus
Deutschland
also die ukrainische Seite hat sich ja
sehr erfreut gezeigt Präsident selenski
hat sich ja persönlich noch mal bedankt
bei bei dem deutschen Bundeskanzler aber
die ukrainische Regierung hat ja von
vornherein klar gemacht dass 90 Panzer
nicht reichen hier ist die Rede von 400
also man sieht hier im Prinzip nur einen
Anfang in dieser Zahl sondern die
ukrainische Seite ist der Meinung dass
das nicht ausreicht aber ein guter
Anfang ist also hunderte von Panzern
davon haben heute einige Kreise in der
Regierung gesprochen das heißt ähm ja
ich glaube das nicht dass das die
ausreichende Zahl ist 90 Panzer vielen
Dank Katrin nach
das war unser zdf-spezial zu den
Reaktionen auf den lieferbeschluss von
Leopard 2 Panzern an die Ukraine vielen
Dank für Ihr Interesse hier geht es
gleich weiter mit dem Handball WM
Viertelfinale Deutschland gegen
Frankreich Ihnen einen schönen Abend auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]